good afternoon when i spoke to
you all last week i explained that the
number of
covid patients going into hospital had
doubled in a fortnight
and i explained that the rate of
infections was climbing steeply
i said that we face the sad reality that
on these figures
we could expect many more daily deaths
and so that's why we announced the
package of restrictions
and stronger enforcement last week
at the same time we've been intensifying
the local
lockdowns in areas where the disease has
been flaring up
and i won't say i know how tough it is
and has been for
these communities and i want to pay a
particular tribute
to the students who are experiencing a
first term
back at university uh unlike anything
they they could have imagined i can
assure you
and assure everybody at universities
that plans are being put in place to
allow
students home safely for christmas
and i wish i could tell you tonight that
the impact of this package
has already begun to appear but it will
take time
to feed through and yesterday we saw the
biggest
rise in daily cases since the pandemic
began
today a further 7108
we've also had a tragic increase in the
number of daily deaths
with 71 yesterday and again today
and these figures show why our plan
is so essential we have to
stick to it together and we should stick
to it with confidence
because there are many ways in which
we're far better prepared
than we were in march we're on track to
hit our target
of being able to conduct 500 000 tests a
day
by the end of october we're already
exceeding
the number of tests per capita that are
conducted in in germany france and spain
we have over two thousand beds
that could be available across uh
nightingale seven
seven nightingale hospitals and we will
be able to go further
if needed we've ordered 32 billion items
of ppe and we'll have a four month
stockpile
of masks visors gowns and other
essentials
for winter by december by the way we
expect
uk manufacturers will meet 70 percent
of the demand for ppe compared with just
one percent before the pandemic
and in the last six months we've more
than trebled the availability
of mechanical ventilators to our nhs
across
the uk to 31 500.
but the best way forwards to protect the
nhs
save lives to keep our children in
school and the economy moving
is to follow the rules wherever we live
so i want to thank everyone
for the fantastic national effort that
we are
seeing and continuing to see and no
matter how impatient
we may be how fed up we may become
there is only one way of doing this and
that's by showing a collective
forbearance common sense and willingness
to make sacrifices for the safety
of others at this critical moment when i
know
uh people will be wanting to know the
details i will be providing
regular updates through these press
conferences
and i have to be clear that if the
evidence requires it
we will not hesitate to take further
measures
that uh would i'm afraid be more costly
than uh the ones we put into effect now
but
if we put in the work together now
then we give ourselves the best possible
chance
of avoiding that outcome and avoiding
further measures i know that some people
will think
we should give up and let the virus take
its course
despite the huge loss of life that that
would potentially entail i have to say
i profoundly disagree and i don't think
it's what the
british people want i don't think they
want to throw in the sponge they want to
fight
and defeat this virus and that is what
we're going to do even as we fight
covid it's vital that people get all the
treatment they need
for other conditions but it must be
clear
if the nhs were to be overwhelmed by
covid
then no one could get any such
care and that's why we must bear down
on this virus now so that we never reach
that point and i'm absolutely confident
that with ever increased testing with
better treatments
and of course with the prospect of a
vaccine
we will get through this so
let's follow the rules wash our hands
cover our faces observe social
distancing
download the app as 14 million of you
have already done
and together we will fight back against
this virus protect
our nhs and save many more lives
i'm now going to hand over to chris
whitney
thank you prime minister uh first slide
please
i thought it was sensible to start off
looking back over
what happened in the first wave of this
pandemic in the uk
and these are the office for national
statistics data the ons data
showing all cause mortality which is the
most important thing to look at
it is because it includes both the
direct deaths from coded
in the red line but also the indirect
deaths
which are the excess deaths over the
yearly average
from all causes because as we know
and it's been discussed many times in
these meetings
you can have people who die because the
health service is overwhelmed
or because the health service is less
able to operate
effectively or in the long run
because of the economic impacts of the
interventions we have so all-cause
mortality is critical
and if you look at this across the
various areas of england and the same is
true in fact if you look in
the other three nations of the united
kingdom what you see is a wave
that happened uh over the period from uh
late march
through to july uh in all course and
covert associated mortality and these
uh data are off are broken down by
region
uh next slide please the pattern we are
seeing in
the current upswing in covid cases
is at this point in time and this may
change rather different
there is on the left what we have is the
total
rate in terms of the amount of kovid
that is being detected on a weekly basis
where darker colors are
the more severe the light the higher
rates
and as you can see at this point in time
uh there is a very heavy concentration
uh in particular areas uh in particular
in the north west
the northeast and parts of the midlands
but on the right what you can see
is also the increase in kovid activity
that is happening over the last seven
days
any color in orange is means it is
increasing and the darker the color the
more rapid the increase
so what you can see in this is that
there's a general increase
across the whole of england and the same
is also true
in scotland wales and northern ireland
with a few
exceptions but a very rapid increase
in particular areas again particularly
in the northeast northwest
and areas of the midlands not
exclusively there
next slide please
and this breaks this down into the
regions of england
but also looking at different age groups
and what you can see in each of these
areas is uh the
multiple age bands from the dark blue
which are the youngest children
up to the black which is those aged 80
or over
and in most regions of england
you're seeing a relatively flat though
gradually rising picture
in terms of number of coveted cases over
time
but if you look at the northeast and
north west and yorkshire and humber and
to a lesser extent the west midlands
you can see a significant rise now
particularly in younger people but
increasingly also
in people who are older and have a
greater risk of having a bad outcome
remembering of course that young people
can also have bad outcomes in terms of
prolonged
symptoms even if they do not have a a
fatal case or one that gets some intense
intensive care so
this increase as you can see is
accelerating
quite rapidly in some of those areas
next slide please
some people are worried that this might
be based just on uh testing capacity so
this
is a different way of looking at the
same thing in the same
areas looking at test positivity rate
and in parts in particular of the
northeast and the
west we've moved from a situation where
by age group we the average might have
less than five
percent of tests being positive up to a
situation where for some age groups
over 15 percent of tests are now
positive this implies
there is a very significant increase in
terms of transmission in these areas
again
quite variable across the country next
slide please
uh it's important to differentiate
between different
age bands between between uh young
younger people children and young adults
and this is just to make the point in
the dark blue
and light blue uh colors uh we have uh
children five to ten
and uh eleven to fourteen and in green
uh we have uh children aged fifteen to
sixteen and in these
uh groups currently the rates are
actually really not changing very much
these are school-age children in the
main
whereas in older uh young children and
young adults
in those 17 uh up to 20 21
and the same is true for other young
adults
the rates are now going quite rapidly
i've chosen to illustrate it with slide
positivity
i could have done this with other routes
so this is important to remember when
people
worry about schooling schools are one of
the areas school-aged children's is one
of the areas where the rates are not
going up
uh and this is true across the country
next slide please
uh there is um i think some uh
some people are wondering whether we
could actually have a situation where
the rates
of infections are going up but we're not
seeing increases in hospitalization
so what this has on this slide is the
admission rates
um on the right to hospital
and the intensive care rates on the left
by age and i think an important thing to
see on this
is that the uh dark blue uh dark dark
line at the top
um and the green line which is the one
below that
in terms of people being hospitalized
are those 85 and
over and 75 to 84. so older people are
getting this
and they are then having to go into
hospital and then
transferring some of them sadly into
intensive care
next slide please and if we look at the
hospitalizations
across the country they follow very much
the pattern you would expect
from the rates of infection so in the
northwest
and the northeast and yorkshire uh the
nhs data
show that the rates of hospitalization
are now climbing steadily
they're at a much lower level than they
were at the beginning of april want to
stress that really clearly
but they are definitely heading upward
at a now
relatively steady and rapid pace
in other areas this is rather slower and
london
and the midlands are between these areas
next slide please the final slide
is just to look again at the intensive
care rates
and people who enter intensive care are
at
significantly increased risk of dying
and this is again just showing
uh in uh the northeast uh
in uh and in the northwest in particular
uh but also uh in london uh to some
extent
uh we're seeing uh a significant uptick
in the number of people who are entering
intensive care this is not yet at a
stage
where it is threatening our ability to
uh have
intensive care cases are still
significant capacity
in the nhs system but this is definitely
heading
the wrong way the final point i'd like
to make
before we go on to just an animation
looking at the spread over time
is about those who do not have kovid
and it is something which my colleagues
in the medical profession have asked me
to stress
really strongly to people this evening
and that is that the nhs is absolutely
open for business
and it is absolutely there not just for
emergencies for cancer care and for all
other kinds of care
so what we're not saying is please don't
go to hospital please don't go to your
gp absolutely not
we definitely are very very keen as a
profession as well as within government
that that continues but we are just
pointing out
that the direction of travel for both
hospitals and intensive care
is clearly going in the wrong direction
particularly in these areas which have
seen
rapid increases in cases we now have an
animation
so this shows a map over time
starting in march lighter colors are
small amounts of covered this is how
it's spread
in the first wave and on the right you
can see the wave
getting steadily darker concentrating at
that stage in particular around london
but also other areas of the midlands
north
uh and uh elsewhere and then due to the
remarkable efforts of the entire nation
everybody coming together we got on top
of that wave
people kept social distancing they kept
all the rules about
han's face in space and we had
significant
uh things that led to people and not
coming together in households
and the uh the amount of covid
went down over time but then it started
to come back again
uh concentrating initially in a small
number of places
but then has steadily spread uh it
initially in these uh areas in the north
uh and
midlands primarily not exclusively uh
but
um uh now potentially spreading
elsewhere if we do not
all take uh all of the various issues
about social distancing
and hands-facing space very seriously
thank you very much
thanks very much chris and i think that
point about the nhs and
uh the capacity of the nhs and the the
openness of the nhs to people to
uh to to go and have their uh
and have their issues dealt with is very
very important
but obviously that becomes much less
possible
uh if we get uh an increased spike in
the disease across the country let's go
to
uh questions from the public first uh
to tear from oldham that the appropriate
support is available
across the uk for young people to be
able to fulfill their potential
moving through these times of
uncertainty as lockdown and kovid 19
have affected young people's mental
health education
and youth unemployment has risen well
thank you uh very much tear i think the
the answer to that is obviously that we
will do everything we can
to help young people through this uh
difficult time
and you'll have seen the package that we
put in place to support
uh people going back to universities
working with the vice chancellors to get
coveted secure
universities and again i i thank uh
students for
the responsible way that they are they
are behaving
uh in in terms of employment uh
for uh for young people tear
the answer is that we really want to
help young people get into
jobs wherever we possibly can that's why
we've launched the kickstart
uh plan two billion pound kickstart plan
to to give people
uh support in jobs give uh employers
uh support uh from the government up to
the value of the living wage
uh to support young people into work and
and i'd also mention uh what we're doing
uh in terms of
of training uh the the lifetime skills
guarantee
that we announced yesterday to give uh
young people people in their in their
20s the ability
to retrain get the jobs uh that are out
there
and we will do everything we can as i've
said repeatedly to put our arms around
the workforce help young people through
this through this pandemic and
bounce back as strongly as we can the
other side